Bonjour à tous! Aujourd'hui, on va parler de quelque
chose avec lequel on est tous familiers,
c'est les couleurs.
Alors les couleurs, c'est l'une des premières choses
qu'on apprend à reconnaître, quand on est gamins.
Et pourtant, on se pose souvent
des questions, par exemple:
qu'est-ce que c'est déjà vraiment une couleur?
Est-ce que le blanc, c'est une couleur? Le gris? Le rose?
Et pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a des règles
pour mélanger les couleurs
qui ne sont pas les mêmes suivant que
c'est de la peinture et de la lumière?
Alors, aujourd'hui, on va essayer de comprendre tout ça,
et pour faire ça, on va s'amuser à prendre
une comparaison entre les couleurs et les sons.
Et vous allez voir, c'est assez instructif.
Si on parle de couleur, du point de vue
sensoriel on parle bien sûr de notre vue,
donc on parle de la lumière
et la lumière physiquement, c'est une
onde électromagnétique.
Quand on considère une onde, une caractéristique
importante dont on peut parler,
c'est sa longueur d'onde.
La longueur d'onde c'est, en gros, la distance qu'il y a
entre deux crêtes du signal électromagnétique.
Une onde électromagnétique elle peut, à priori,
avoir n'importe quelle longueur d'onde
et suivant cette longueur d'onde, en fait
on va lui donner un nom différent.
Par exemple, si la longueur d'onde
est à peu près d'un mètre,
on parle d'onde radio, c'est les ondes
qui servent à transmettre la radio.
Si la longueur d'onde est plutôt autour
du centimètre, on parle de micro-onde,
oui, évidemment, les ondes qu'il y a
dans les micro-ondes, mais pas que.
Si on veut avoir des ondes
beaucoup beaucoup plus petites,
par exemple avec des longueurs d'onde
de l'ordre du nanomètre (nm) ou en dessous,
c'est ce qu'on appelle des rayons X.
Les rayons X, c'est comme les ondes radio ou les ondes micro-ondes ce sont des ondes électromagnétiques.
Et alors là dedans,
les ondes que l'on peut capter avec nos yeux, c'est-à-dire
les ondes qui correspondent à la lumière visible
ont des longueurs d'onde qui sont situées en gros entre 400 et 700 nm.
Et là, il y a déjà un truc remarquable à noter,
parmi tout le spectre possible
des ondes électromagnétiques,
notre vue ne permet d'en distinguer
qu'une toute petite partie,
celles dont les longueurs d'onde sont
comprises entre 400 et 700 nm.
A priori, des ondes électromagnétiques,
il en existe à toutes les longueurs d'onde,
depuis le nanomètre et même en-dessous du
nanomètre, jusqu'au mètre et même plusieurs mètres.
Je vous ai promis que dans cette vidéo on allait
s'amuser à comparer les couleurs et les sons,
alors rappelons brièvement ce que c'est qu'un son.
Un son c'est aussi une onde mais ce n'est pas
une onde électromagnétique,
c'est une onde de pression de l'air.
Pour les ondes sonores on peut aussi
parler de leur longueur d'onde
mais c'est plutôt habituel de parler de
leur fréquence, c'est-à-dire
du nombre de vibrations qu'elles ont à chaque seconde.
La fréquence et la longueur d'onde c'est
en fait deux facettes de la même chose,
en réalité elles sont reliées par
la vitesse de propagation de l'onde, mais bon,
allez savoir pourquoi, en fait pour la lumière on a
plutôt pris l'habitude de parler en longueur d'onde
et pour le son on parle plutôt en fréquence.
L'unité de la fréquence c'est le Hertz (Hz)
donc là par exemple, je vous fait écouter un son qui est à 440 Hz.
Comme pour la lumière, notre oreille n'est
pas capable de détecter toutes les ondes sonores,
ça dépend des personnes et de l'age
mais en gros notre ouïe
est sensible aux sons qui sont compris
entre 20 et 20 000 Hz.
20 Hz c'est les sons les plus graves
et en-dessous on a les infrasons
et 20 000 Hz c'est les sons les plus aigus qu'on peut
percevoir et au-dessus c'est ce qu'on appelle les ultrasons.
Voilà, ça c’était les petits rappels concernant le son,
mais on va revenir à la lumière et surtout aux couleurs.
Imaginez que je prenne une onde électromagnétique
dont la longueur d'onde est 400 nm
et que je la balance dans votre œil.
Qu'est-ce que vous allez voir?
Et bien vous allez voir ça, du violet.
Si l'onde avait une longueur de 450 nm ça serait plutôt indigo, à 500 nm du bleu, vers 550 nm du vert,
un peu en dessous de 600 nm du jaune,
un peu au-dessus de 600 nm du orange
et à 650 nm et jusqu'à 700 nm ça serait du rouge.
Donc si je balance dans votre œil des ondes lumineuses
dont la fréquence est comprise entre 400 et 700 nm,
la perception que vous allez avoir c'est celle de couleurs
qui balayent ce qu'on a l'habitude d'appeler
les couleurs de l'arc-en-ciel.
Ce qu'il faut bien comprendre dans cette affaire,
c'est que la couleur, c'est avant tout une perception,
c'est un truc qui est fabriqué par notre cerveau.
Au départ les ondes électromagnétiques n'ont pas
de couleur, elles ont une longueur d'onde
et c'est seulement une fois que ça arrive dans votre œil,
que votre cerveau l'interprète et que ça vous donne une
sensation qu'on a pris l'habitude d'appeler les couleurs.
On va compliquer un peu notre expérience maintenant,
imaginez que je ne vous balance pas une onde
électromagnétique avec une certaine longueur d'onde,
mais que je vous balance deux ondes
électromagnétiques en même temps
avec des longueurs d'onde différentes.
Par exemple une onde dont
la longueur d'onde est 550 nm
et une autre onde dont la longueur d'onde est 650 nm.
Je vous rappelle, normalement 550 nm c'est
quelque chose qu'on voit plutôt vert
et 650 nm c'est quelque chose
qu'on verrait plutôt rouge.
Alors, si je vous balance les deux ondes en même
temps, qu'est-ce que vous allez voir comme couleur?
Du rouge et du vert en même temps?
Ou bien du rouge et du vert l'un après
l'autre?
Et bien non, vous allez voir du jaune.
Je pense que ce résultat ne devrait
pas trop vous surprendre,
vous savez certainement que quand on mélange
de la lumière verte et de la lumière rouge,
on obtient de la lumière jaune.
Mais bon, fondamentalement c'est quand même
un petit peu perturbant comme résultat.
Ca veut dire que si je vous envoie donc
deux ondes de 550 et 650 nm,
ça va vous faire exactement la même
impression, la même sensation que si je vous envoie
une seule onde de 600 nm.
On a vu, une seule onde de 600 nm
ça correspond à du jaune.
Pour bien comprendre en quoi ce
résultat est vraiment bizarre,
je voudrais qu'on fasse la comparaison
avec les sons et la musique.
Allons-y, là je vais vous jouer un Do.
un Ré... et un Mi
Maintenant, attention, je vous joue
le Do et le Mi en même temps.
Si vous vous concentrez un peu, vous pouvez
entendre distinctement le Do et le Mi,
un musicien avec une bonne oreille serait même
capable d'identifier les deux notes jouées ensemble
sans que j'aie besoin de dire quelles notes c'était.
Donc si je vous joue deux notes en même temps
vous pouvez les distinguer toutes les deux,
alors que si je vous balance deux ondes
électromagnétiques en même temps,
vous voyez une espèce de moyenne des deux,
vous ne vous rendez pas compte que c'est deux ondes.
Si notre oreille marchait comme nos yeux,
ça voudrait dire que, par exemple quand je joue
un Do et un Mi simultanément,
vous entendriez un Ré.
Ça serait bizarre, non?
Si c'était ça d'ailleurs, la musique ça serait vachement
pauvre, on serait incapables d'entendre des accords...
et à la place on entendrait juste des
espèces de notes moyennes.
Ça serait un peu chiant.
Donc on a vu qu'une différence fondamentale
entre notre ouïe et notre vue
c'est que nos oreilles sont capables de décomposer
les différentes fréquences d'un son.
Si je joue deux notes en même temps,
mon oreille reconnaît qu'il y a deux notes,
alors qu'à côté de ça, notre vue est incapable
de faire la différence entre jaune et
vert mélangé avec rouge.
Alors pour comprendre d'où vient cette
bizarrerie en fait, il faut se pencher
sur la manière dont fonctionne la perception
des ondes électromagnétiques.
Dans notre œil, sur notre rétine, il y a quatre types
différents de cellules qui servent de capteurs lumineux,
il y a les bâtonnets dont on ne va pas trop parler
aujourd'hui, qui servent surtout à la vision nocturne,
et puis il y a les cônes dont il existe
trois types différents.
Les cônes ont un mode de détection
qui est vachement plus pauvre
que les tympans de nos oreilles, par exemple.
C'est-à-dire que quand un cône
reçoit une onde lumineuse,
il n'est pas capable de reconnaître la
longueur d'onde de la lumière, la seule
chose qu'il est capable de reconnaître
c'est qu'il a reçu une onde lumineuse
et donc d'envoyer un signal du genre:
"ah ouais, là j'ai repéré un truc" et c'est tout.
La petite particularité c'est que
les trois types de cônes que nous avons,
ont des sensibilités différentes aux
longueurs d'onde de la lumière.
On a des cônes qui vont réagir aux
longueurs d'onde autour de 450 nm,
des cônes qui réagissent vers 550 nm et
d'autres plutôt dans la zone 600 - 650 nm.
Alors, par raccourci on a tendance à appeler ces cônes,
les cônes bleus, verts et rouges,
c'est quand même une petite entorse
parce que vous voyez que le cône rouge
n'est quand même pas très très
éloigné du cône vert, mais bon...
Maintenant qu'on sait ça, on peut reprendre
notre expérience où on balançait
deux longueurs d'onde en même temps et
essayer de comprendre ce qui se passe.
Dans ce genre de situation, le cône vert va
particulièrement réagir à l'onde qui est à 550 nm
et le cône rouge va plutôt réagir
à l'onde qui est à 650 nm
et je vous rappelle, les cônes
n'identifient pas la longueur d'onde,
la seule chose qu'ils sont capables de dire c'est:
"Ah ouais, là j'ai vu un truc".
Donc si vous balancez ces deux ondes en même temps,
les deux types de cônes, les cônes verts et
les cônes rouges vont tous les deux réagir en disant:
"ah ouais, là j'ai vu un truc"
Maintenant, si je balance une onde à 600 nm,
les cônes verts vont y être un petit peu sensibles
donc eux aussi vont réagir et dire:
"ouais, j'ai capté un truc"
et les cônes rouges, pareil, ils vont réagir et dire:
ouais, moi aussi j'ai capté un truc.
Donc on voit bien qu'à cause de cette manière
de détecter, on a deux phénomènes physiques
qui sont à la base assez différents, c'est-à-dire,
deux ondes à 550 et 650 nm d'un côté
et puis une onde à 600 nm de l'autre
qui vont provoquer exactement la même
perception, la même sensation,
ce qu'on a pris coutume d'appeler le jaune.
Et ça c'est très important parce que ça montre vraiment
bien que la couleur n'est pas un concept physique,
c'est vraiment un concept biologique, c'est-à-dire que
c'est quelque chose qui est créé par notre cerveau,
c'est une interprétation c'est une perception.
D'ailleurs cette idée que de la lumière rouge et de
la lumière verte ensemble ça fait de la lumière jaune,
ce qu'on appelle de la synthèse additive,
je me souviens bien, c'est quelque chose que
j'avais appris en cours de physique au collège
et c'est une connerie parce qu'en fait ce n'est pas un
phénomène physique, c'est vraiment de la bio
la synthèse additive.
Si nos cônes étaient différents, la synthèse additive
se passerait de manière différente,
la preuve, les daltoniens ne voient pas les couleurs
de la même manière que les autres.
Encore une fois de ce point de vue-là, l’œil est
quand même vachement moins fort que l'oreille.
Notre ouïe nous permet d'entendre des accords
et les très bons musiciens sont même capables
de nommer les différentes notes des accords,
c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont capables de vraiment
décomposer le signal sonore
et de remonter aux fréquences qui le composent,
c'est-à-dire de remonter à la vraie
nature physique du signal.
A côté de ça, notre vue, la perception
qu'on a des ondes électromagnétiques,
c'est juste les couleurs, c'est quelque chose d'assez
pauvre par rapport à la vraie nature physique du signal.
Une autre manière de le dire, c'est qu'on ne peut pas
reconnaître des accords de couleurs
Alors continuons un peu notre exploration des couleurs.
Vous avez déjà remarqué que dans
l'arc-en-ciel il n'y a pas de rose?
C'est vrai, il y a du bleu, du violet, du rouge, mais
il n'y a pas de rose. Alors pourquoi il n'y a pas le rose?
Le rose c'est cette sensation que notre cerveau fabrique
quand le cône bleu et le cône rouge sont
tous les deux excités par des ondes lumineuses,
mais pas, le cône vert.
Vous voyez que ça ne peut pas marcher
avec une seule longueur d'onde,
il en faut forcément au moins deux
et dans un arc-en-ciel, en chaque point,
il n'y a qu'une seule longueur d'onde
donc il ne peut pas y avoir
de lumière rose dans un arc-en-ciel.
Ça c'était pour le rose.
Et maintenant, le blanc.
Est-ce que c'est une couleur le blanc?
On a dit une couleur c'est une sensation,
c'est une construction de notre cerveau
et donc le blanc, oui, c'est une couleur
et c'est plus précisément la sensation
que notre cerveau fabrique
quand les trois types de cônes sont
excités à peu près au même niveau
et il y a plein de manières de provoquer cette sensation,
il suffit de trouver des manières
de stimuler les types de cônes.
Par exemple on peut le faire en
balançant des ondes ayant
plein plein plein de longueurs d'onde différentes,
c'est ce que fait par exemple le soleil
ou bien une bonne lampe à incandescence.
Ou bien on peut se contenter de balancer
juste trois longueurs d'onde qui vont bien
et qui vont venir exciter chacun des trois cônes.
Ça c'est le principe des écrans LCD par exemple, dans
un pixel d'écran LCD en fait il y a trois sous pixels,
un rouge, un vert et un bleu,
et ces trois sous-pixels sont chacun capable de
vous balancer ces longueurs d'onde spécifiques
qui viennent exciter vos trois types de cônes.
Donc si les trois sous-pixels sont allumés,
vous recevez les trois longueurs d'onde
et donc vous avez la sensation de blanc.
Alors tout ça attention, il faut bien voir que,
je vous ai dit, c'est un phénomène biologique,
c'est-à-dire que c'est lié aux cônes qu'on possède
et toutes les espèces animales n'ont
pas les mêmes types de cônes.
Il y a certains poissons comme le poisson rouge
par exemple qui ont quatre cônes différents.
Il y a des oiseaux, par exemple le pigeon qui en ont cinq.
Et le record ça serait une espèce de
crevette qu'on appelle la crevette-mante
et qui en aurait entre douze et seize.
Le poisson rouge, par exemple, il a un
quatrième cône qui est dans l'ultraviolet,
ce qui veut dire qu'un poisson rouge qui
regarderait une télé LCD par exemple,
pour lui ça ne serait pas une retranscription fidèle
de la réalité parce que ça n'enverrait pas d'UV.
Pour nous, si quelque chose émet
du rouge et de l'ultraviolet,
on le voit de la même manière
que s'il émettait juste du rouge
et pour le poisson rouge ça serait différent.
Je termine par un dernier truc
amusant au sujet des couleurs.
On l'a dit, la couleur c'est vraiment
un concept biologique,
la physique ignore complètement le concept
de couleur, elle ne parle que de longueur d'onde
et donc si on considère un objet,
par exemple un tee-shirt,
et qu'on se demande quelle couleur il a,
en fait le tee-shirt n'a pas une couleur, la seule
chose qu'il ait c'est un spectre de réflexion,
c'est-à-dire qu'il va réfléchir d'une manière possiblement
différente toutes les longueurs d'onde de la lumière.
et donc, un tee-shirt qui va réfléchir les ondes
de 600 nm par exemple, il va nous paraître jaune
et un autre tee-shirt qui réfléchirait les longueurs
d'onde 550 et 650, il va nous paraître jaune aussi,
mais physiquement ce n'est pas le même tee-shirt.
Il y a une manière de se rendre compte que ces
deux tee-shirts qui à priori ont l'air tous les deux jaunes,
sont en fait différents.
Pour ça on peut s'amuser à essayer de les éclairer
avec une lumière qui soit exactement de 600 nm.
Le premier tee-shirt, vu qu'il réfléchit la lumière
à 600 nm, il va réfléchir et donc il nous apparaîtra jaune,
et le deuxième tee-shirt,
s'il réfléchit uniquement 550 et 650,
il ne va pas réfléchir cette lumière
et donc il nous apparaîtra noir.
Si on balance toutes les longueurs d'onde
en même temps comme c'est le cas avec le soleil
et la plupart des lampes,
on ne voit pas de différence
entre ces deux tee-shirts,
mais si on s'amuse à les éclairer avec des lumières
qui ont des longueurs d'onde très spécifiques,
alors là la différence peut apparaître.
Une conséquence amusante de ça,
au coucher du soleil, vous savez le
soleil a l'air un peu orangé
et si on compare ça, par exemple avec les lampes
qu'il y a dans les tunnels d'autoroute,
elles ont aussi l'air orangées.
On pourrait penser que c'est un peu le
même genre de lumière,
sauf qu'en réfléxion sur les objets qui
nous entourent, ce n'est pas du tout pareil,
sous un tunnel d'autoroute, tout à l'air orangeasse,
alors qu'au coucher du soleil, tout est très beau.
Donc, même si le soleil couchant
et la lumière d'autoroute
ont en vision directe, à peu près la
même couleur, en réflexion sur les objets
ce n'est pas du tout la même chose
et donc la raison est que
la lumière du soleil contient
toutes les longueurs d'onde,
donc elle fait se réfléchir
toutes les couleurs de tous les objets
alors que la lumière de tunnel d'autoroute,
c'est une seule longueur d'onde ou presque,
centrée autour de l'orange
et donc elle ne permet de réfléchir que de l'orange.
Comme quoi la couleur c'est quand même
quelque chose de compliqué.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo, je
vous en recommande deux autres
que vous pouvez aller voir pour aller plus loin,
il y a une vidéo de Scilabus
qui parle justement de la couleur des tee-shirts et
notamment elle montre comment construire un spectro
avec juste un bout de CD et une webcam,
c'est assez amusant.
Puis une vidéo de Bruce de e-penser
qui parle des cônes
et notamment des cônes rouges et
de la manière dont ils ont évolué
et dont notre perception du rouge
a évolué au cours des temps.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo, si elle vous a plu,
comme d'hab n'hésitez pas à la partager,
aidez-moi à faire connaître la chaîne.
Vous pouvez me retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux
pour les actus de la chaîne, sur Facebook ou sur Twitter.
Vous pouvez me soutenir sur
Tipeee si le cœur vous en dit.
Merci beaucoup à tous les Tipeurs qui me soutiennent
et vous pouvez aussi aller voir mon livre,
j'ai sorti ça il y a quelques jours,
c'est un livre qui s'appelle:
"Mais qui a attrapé le bison de Higgs?"
et il est disponible dans toutes les bonnes librairies.
Merci et à bientôt!
Sous-titres: Warteks